don't take the couch you'll sleep on the  roof in Casablanca that's where husbands  go they're watching us now kiss me  so you were beautiful I'm good being  good at this kind of work is not very  beautiful absolute war you have the  place when the war is over what matter  where I am  found each other  come with me in London come with me you  be my wife  I love you with all my heart  there's no easy way to say what we're  about to say we suspect your wife as a  german spies insane if you were right  all this will be forgotten but if she is  it will execute her with your own hand  and if you do not comply you're behind  72 hours we shall know for sure is this  a game the test everything is a test  you're different with me last night  different like you were angry she's the  mother my child it isn't true I'm proven  say her you've been Natan they disobeyed  orders you're scaring me  when the war is over won't matter right  hey what happened to my kiss  good being good at the